the real Stakes that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
the media are working overtime to get
you wound up about nonsense and it's all
a sideshow so Don't Take Your Eye Off
the ball today what matters is
understanding two camps that make up
America's Stark divide
now on the one side we have what the
angle calls the regime it's a coalition
of Democrats Republicans the media and
certain portions of the business
Community all of whom are committed to
an agenda that empowers the super rich
in various International organizations
now on the other side there's a growing
populist conservative movement that's
determined to use power and leverage of
the United States government to empower
working-class Americans and they're
going to do that by bringing up living
standards and ensuring that they have
more control over their own lives
now the stakes for the country couldn't
be higher Gallup just released results
of an eye-opening poll
it asked what do you think is the most
important problem facing this country
today 10 percent said the economy 11
said immigration
fifteen percent said inflation in
topping the list 21 said the government
and poor leadership is the major problem
yeah more Americans say the federal
government which is supposed to be
working for us
is the biggest problem out there
and the other problems like high prices
are caused by The Reckless government
policies so why are we all surprised it
makes perfect sense to the angle because
for the regime the federal bureaucracy
exists to carry out its policies no
matter who the voters elect
so if we pick someone like a trump or a
DeSantis the regime will expect Federal
bureaucrats to do everything possible to
undermine that president to prevent any
significant changes to the regime's
policies
on the other hand when we have a
President Biden the regime will move
forward with measures that are so
patently illegal such as that loan
forgiveness scheme and they'll be livid
if the courts try to stop them
we populists believe that our government
should be of by and for the people and
that the voters not the bureaucrats
should set the course on policy
and of course the regime wants open
borders we just talked about this
because they believe that it is immoral
to the United States to deny entry to
anyone who wants to come here
but also because it gives big business
an unlimited supply of cheap labor that
it can use to hold wages down
well we populists believe that being an
American citizen is a privilege that
should come with real benefits not just
obligations
and we know that closing the Border
would inevitably lead to higher wages
for American workers
for the regime defending Europe though
that's the top foreign policy goal for
the United States
Europe is the heart of globalization
after all it's the home to the European
Union the World Trade Organization the
World Health Organization and countless
other outposts of globalization
they're all opposed to the Primacy of
the nation-state our sovereignty and
believe me they all speak the same
language
what we are about is standing up for
basic principles basic rights and a
rules-based international order a lot of
people would like to see there there are
two orders in this world
this is a huge mistake we need
a single Global Order
the regime also sees Europe as the model
for our future a technocratic state
where elections don't carry much weight
in most policy decisions are made by
unelected bureaucrats
so from their perspective Europe cannot
be allowed to fail
we will be with the Ukrainian people for
as long as it takes for them to defend
themselves as I told president zielinski
when he was here we're with you for as
long as it takes
as long as it takes no matter what it
costs
even to the point of risking nuclear war
it's always America first you're up
first excuse me and Americans last
but the populists believe the real
threat lies in Asia and that's 78 years
after the end of World War II the
Europeans should really be managing
their own situations we've worked
together on getting some of our allies
to pay their fair share at some point I
think it's going to have to go higher I
mean Germany honestly is not paying
their fair share I have a great feeling
for Germany but they're not paying what
they should be paying so we're paying
for a big proportion of NATO which
basically is protecting Europe
Bingo they hated him for saying that he
was a hundred percent right
actually though because we're also
paying for a disproportionate share of
Europe's proxy war with Russia now
and then of course there's China which
the regime sees as primarily a helpful
partner
regime spokesman like John Kerry see
China as an ally
what can be done about China China
interestingly enough China has a plan
more electric vehicles
will be put on the road over the next
year or so in China than in all the rest
of the world put together
and the Chamber of Commerce and other
business groups they see China as a
potential market and a source of cheap
labor Silicon Valley in Hollywood they
see China as a place to sell their
intellectual property works for them
because the regime doesn't really care
about what happens to Asia they're
fundamentally indifferent to the fact
that China is using their gargantuan
Trade Surplus with the United States to
build the most powerful military in the
world
well we populists believe that China has
an existential threat to the freedom of
Americans that we should stop helping
the to make the CCP rich and that our
military and our foreign policy should
be refocused on the threat from China
and let's face it the regime sees
climate change as an urgent danger that
will destroy Humanity unless Americans
accept drastic reductions in our
standard of living
they want us to live in smaller spaces
ditch our gas appliances and certainly
ditch our automobiles they want to
reverse almost all the progress we've
enjoyed since the end of World War II
and kram us into congested cities and
force us to use Beijing style bike Lanes
well the same among us see that as just
another rerun of what they did with
covid
an agenda designed to control us and it
will do almost nothing to address the
alleged problem that they're citing
destroying our economy preventing
Innovation it's not going to save the
planet it's just going to make it easier
for China and other countries to push us
around
and finally for the regime the greatest
threat to humanity other than climate
change comes from social conservatives
or whatever faith
they're far more dangerous than the CCP
or even foreign terrorists for that
matter
the regime knows that people whose hope
lies in heaven and who pay more
attention to the Bible than to the media
aren't easily manipulated or bossed
around
this is why they seek to upend
traditional institutions like law
enforcement the military and the nuclear
family well while the image of the
nuclear family is often held up as the
ideal and only form a family can take
whether or not that's true seems to vary
by social group and region it's
important to remember whatever form
shape or size it takes we have the power
to Define what family should look like
for ourselves
and of course anti-American propaganda
is their lifeblood which the populists
are working to expose especially parents
fighting the radicalism in our schools
today
so all these policy differences that I
laid out they're big they're serious
and as we ramp up for 2024 they should
be our Focus not whatever shiny objects
the Press dangles to divide us
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else